- - Au lendemain de sa victoireà
l'l'émission "Canada's Got
TaTalent", la chanteuse Jeanick
FoFourniersavoure pleinement
totout ce qui lui arrive.
JEJEANICK FOURNIER, chanteuse
gagagnante de Canada's Got Talet
- - Je me suis dit :
peperforme, fille, chante!
TuTu as l'opportunité d'être là,
prprofiter de chaque seconde,
rerentre tes deux pieds
dadans le sol, go for it!
DeDe voir mon beau Yoann assis
enen avant de moi, en plus,
avavec quelques amis et
lala famille. Je me disais : pee
papas, non plus, que Simon Cowel
esest assis dans le milieu, là,l
fafaut pas que tu penses à ça, !
IlIl faut que tu te dises :
chchante, bébé, chante!
♪♪ ♪ ♪
- - Sa prestation a fait vivre e
grgrandes émotions à sa famille,
réréunie au Lac-Saint-Jean.
FRFRANCE OTIS
mmère de Jeanic/I/Inier
- - C'est elle, c'est elle,
pupuis je pleurais, puis
jeje criais! C'est terrible!
C'C'est tellement "émotionnant".
PuPuis elle a tellement travailé
dudur, hein! Elle était prête.
♪♪ ♪ ♪
- - L'artiste se démarque
dedepuis de nombreuses années
susur les scènes de la région,
dadans différentes productions.
ROROBERT DORÉ
prproducteur, Québec Issime
- - Ça pouvait pas arriver
àà une meilleure personne.
TuTu sais, Jeanick, en plus
d'd'être une grande voix,
c'c'est une bonne personne.
MAMARTIN LAROSE, propriétaire
LeLe Studio Septentrio
- - C'est une grande dame
dede la chanson, puis elle
mémérite tout ce qui lui arrive.
- - Une voix puissante et
unun coeur immense... Depuis
prprès d'une quinzaine d'année,
JeJeanick Fournier est préposée
auaux bénéficiaires à la Maison
dede soins palliatifs du Saguen.
ElElle est reconnue pour son
dédévouement, sa bonne humeur et
sasa bienveillance. Ses collègus
onont suivi la finale avec
bebeaucoup d'intérêt.
- - Moi j'ai eu la chance de
l'l'écouter ici. Je l'l'ai écoue
dadans la chambre d'un patient
avavec un patient, je travaillas
avavec une préposée, une collèg.
FaFait qu'on l'a écoutée avec
unun patient puis on criait.
- - Je criais! Quand j'ai vu que
c'c'était elle qui était la grae
gagagnante, j'étais vraiment
cocontente pour elle.
VrVraiment, un gros bravo!
♪♪ ♪ ♪
- - À quelques jours de son 50e
ananniversaire, cette aventure
mamarque un tournant dans
sasa carrière et dans sa vie.
- - C'est sûr que ce matin, je e
susuis réveillée avec mon amourx
pupuis j'ai dit : j'ai gagné
"C"Canada's Got Talent", chéri,
pupuis j'ai dit, 150 000 $,
tutu comprends? Je vis dans
unun petit 4 et demi, dans
unune merveilleuse coopérative
àà Chicoutimi. Je veux offrir
dedeux chambres à mes enfants,
jeje veux vivre ça, je me cassei
plplus la tête! Tu sais, je veux
plplus me casser la tête pour ç!
JeJe veux juste chanter, aimer,
dodonner, vivre avec mes beaux
cococos d'amour, ma famille
etet mes amis tout le tour,
pupuis profiter de tout ça.
(a(applaudissements)
- - Ici Julie Larouche,
R Radio-Canada, Saguena